when you come to a place like New York
City first of all you are bombarded with
people who are like you only better so
you may be you may be the best violinist
in hot coffee Texas and you get off the
train in Penn Station and to your horror
there's somebody out there begging you
know playing the violin and she's better
than you and so that makes you just dig
down deep and just practice practice
practice so you see all these people who
are like you the second thing in New
York City a place like New York gives
you is tons of people who are so unlike
you and they they differ with you and
they they see things very differently
and they bombard you with objections and
arguments and questions and that makes
you really either come up with a better
rationale for what you want to do than
you ever would have gotten before or it
makes you incorporate new ideas and so
the diversity you have so many people
like you and so many people unlike you
that it creates better enterprises it's
it's it's a hothouse for coming up with
new models and new ideas and I think
actually New York made me a far better
minister I don't think it has to make
you secular I think it can make you more
Orthodox but you'll be different
you